for the last two decades the MOBO Awards
have been a celebration of music of
black origin but for its founder Kanye
King it's been a relentless battle
against systemic racism within the music
industry not many black executives at a
senior level in the music industry you
know I would like to see their ethnicity
pay gap reporting mandatory unless we
feel comfortable having those
discussions about inequalities erase
progress will not be made musician Nadia
rose was signed to a major label and
says the lack of diversity there had a
huge effect on her career and would
always feel like my white male
counterparts that was science and the
label would always have you know I think
the budgets were great are they they
related to the ANR's there and everyone
knew how to market these particular
artists because they could relate and
then therefore they was capitalizing off
of them but then you're you're leaving
out the black women that you don't
understand where to put or how to push
and it just it wasn't a very comfortable
situation to be in according to the
latest diversity report in 2018 black
and ethnic minority representation in
the music industry as a whole was 17 0.8
percent it was higher among young
workers at twenty five point nine
percent but Bame representation among
senior managers was still only just over
18 percent earlier this month leading
names from the music industry took part
in a blackout Tuesday amid calls that
the time for genuine change is long
overdue the industry body UK music
acknowledges there are problems and will
be publishing its own plan of action in
the coming weeks I think those who sit
on boards should voluntarily leave
that's a really strong sign of action
and make space for individuals who
deservedly should be in those positions
kanya King says racism is the worst
pandemic we're facing but she also
believes this is a watershed moment and
change is still possible
Lucy Casa Sky News